see uh our place on reddit have you
heard about this oh you're telling me
this is this is awesome this is this is
really cool basically reddit does this
is like a uh like april fools thing they
did back like 2017 then they brought it
back this year basically what happens is
every little dot you can can't really
even see it on here every little dot is
a uh a pixel that you're able to place
if you have an account
and there's just like i think it's like
a million pixels like the whole plot and
basically what you do is you go and you
place a pixel and you can only place one
like every 20 minutes so basically you
have an entire like all these
communities that got together and
they're trying to place pixels in order
to like create
visuals
and then over time they fill up the
whole thing and then you have different
groups like warring over each other for
land
and so they're trying to like place
pixels over each other so like they
dropped uh like every time the american
flag gets dropped people try to like
take it over
and so like they post it and then like
there's a whole thing where like the
trans flag was up and then the germans
had their little thing and so the trans
people and germans were fighting
and all these different like sub
communities are like fighting and
warring with each other
through this like sandbox i just think
this is brilliant like communal effort
right here to organize the amount of
people necessary to make that flag or
make these little what is that ozil i
don't know what that is but this is a
genius dude i mean they would do that on
minecraft like that you'd meet in the
little world and then build like the
starship enterprise
cube by cube yeah exactly but can you do
it 20 minutes at a time i think that's
so crazy about it like you need so many
people
this isn't the best depiction of it
because you can't see how small the
little pixel is yeah right like that
american flag is how many pixels mark i
mean thousands thousands so it's like
you need thousands of people organized
knowing exactly where they're gonna
place which color where and doing it
every 20 minutes
ah so cool people have jobs anymore i
know
i love that incel's found a hobby
now this is i i just think it's 1200
goes a long way
group organization no this is fires it's
kind of sick right and the indians had a
big faction what do they do where that
[ __ ] is at they put an indian flag
somewhere that [ __ ] was probably taking
over you know it's over you feel pride
when you see your flag though you see an
american flag fire then you see a
chinese flag yeah like get that [ __ ] out
of here they did yeah well they're
starting to yeah no you got the indian
flag right here right
oh there it is yeah y'all doing your
thing good call bruh yeah
you